[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
another exciting episode of honest
trailer commentaries commentaries
commentaries
today we're talking about mean girls
it's like a monster truck rally here
sunday sunday sunday
we'll be talking about the trailer
telling you our behind the scenes
thoughts uh
afterwards you'll see some jokes that
didn't make the cut uh we'll respond to
some viewer hate mail love and hate mail
uh and then we will tease up next week's
honest trailer if you stick around to
the very end with me
lon and danielle hey guys hey hello
now this is always a tricky one uh when
it comes up on the schedule that you are
to uh
lovingly lampoon and and give you the
honest truth about a movie that is
honestly
really good really good and funny
and was already like self-aware in a way
like it's
kind of already poking fun at the genre
and the style so like what
is left for the three of us but who are
we if not to give the people what they
want and this is one of the most
requested
movies um you know i would love i would
love to
do a troll two or uh do we're just
watching clips from cobra before this
started i'd love to get cobra
but people aren't asking for cobra every
week uh damn it
we're uh we're trying to work with like
the thinnest like tony roma's ribs
whereas there's like a turkey drumstick
like right over there
tony roma's is such a deep cut yeah
that's old man comedy right there we
have both tango and cash just waiting
for us
sitting in the wings yeah yeah a full
turkey sitting on a street corner like a
power up in streets of rage
just crouch over it we'll we'll go back
to full health the village people movie
can't stop the music is just
sitting there never touched but what's
that what's that kiss movie where they
haunt the theme park
scooby crossover something like that
yeah
anyways they met they met the mystery
gang at one point no no there was a
scoop to do
there was a full kiss theme park movie
live action
um kiss meets the phantom of the park
there
good movie right great movie come on
there's it's like they're they're it's
dated in some spots because it's 20
years old
and uh and i think we we sort of make a
lot of hay there
because that's like it's a good region
for us to hang out but yeah otherwise
it's a great movie holds up really well
it's still funny
well so here's the thing um that i have
noticed that that comes up when we talk
about things that are dated
i think that we and i think the we when
i say the royal we
all of us we give way more um we're
less kind to things that are dated in
the last 10 years
than we are to things that are dated 25
years ago
like right yes if we were doing uh uh
i don't know heathers
is way more dated and the funniest movie
with a school shooting in it
yeah i mean right like the revenge of
the nerds era or something you're just
like oh my god it's like radioactive now
right but and i feel like because i i i
don't know i think and i'm when i again
i say
the royal we i mean like the culture i
think that for some things we're like
yeah we know but that was our
grandparents stuff but when it comes to
our stuff we feel very much like
yeah we also liked it and we were there
and we're sorry
um especially in the last like things
that came out in the last 10 years so
when we do say those things it is
it is obviously like we're acknowledging
it but yes you know that older movies
were obviously worse
yeah i mean we the the comedy of
2004 um i think
mean girls is like the tamest version of
it because at the time
it was like dane cook and like carlos
mencia were like
it was never like a right wing troll
like of course it was always going to be
you know like relatively within the
scope of appropriateness
i'm just saying it was like a time when
like shock humor was like oh my god you
can't say that but you said it that was
the funniest thing you could do
yeah they gave us like daniel tosh yeah
speaking of shock
humor and dane cook i will not say the
thing but his literal symbol
that was his symbol was if you were to
make a peace sign and then for some
reason also just like have like your
thumbnail
like you're like you're picking out like
that was like his symbol that was like
the thing he used for tours
that was his merch thing um i can't
think of anything that is more
encompassing of that era of comedy and
the fact that everyone was lining up to
see that this
well look it's not that funny anymore
but by the way i don't think anything
uh 15 years old should be that funny
anymore
i think that if we look back on the
movies today and we're not saying oh
that's kind of dated comedy then
we've frozen as a culture and we should
just stop but i mean this is
specifically about
team culture which is ever changing and
morphing anyway so i mean this is like a
generation ago
youth culture so of course it's not
going to be exactly relevant to today i
mean
we're talking about that pre-tick-tock
world here no cell phones
that's what that's it still holds up and
yeah that knows
yeah it's still it's still a good just
like
teen coming of age story or a high
school area however you want to slice it
um
and the fact that there's a lot of
laughs still on top of that is and it
it has that stay like the 30 rock like
there's good characters you can invest
in it as a real scenario
but it's also like really heightened and
like silly
and like it has that goofiness like that
saturday night live side to it
and i think the balance works really
well for her whether it's here or kimmy
schmidt
or 30 rock it's like it kind of fits
that whole tone yeah i was surprised how
much
slapstick there was in it looking back a
lot of people getting
a little dunked in the face with a boom
box they're like oh you fell into a
trash can
which is timeless right and it just also
has like anything for a laugh
sensibility like there's kind of a
sitcom logic like
when you really start to think about
these she doesn't even go here lying
like well
how would this girl have even gotten to
the assembly it doesn't even really make
sense
but it's like oh it's just a joke and
then you move on and like she's really
good at that kind of rapid fire
sort of right yeah super funny um
we all like the movie now let's roll the
trailer and see how we
tore it to shreds
[Music]
from your slightly problematic fave tina
fey
a hundred years from now people will see
my work and think
wow that is actually pretty racist comes
a ruthless tale of pointless cruelty
full of miserable teenagers trapped in a
hell of their own creation basically the
most honest high school movie ever made
mean girls i i hate to put this to the
panel but
is this the most true to your high
school experiences
of of any high school uh kids movie now
a little showing up on first the first
day and making two
battling groups of friends it does not
exactly align with my
uh my high school experience danielle
i grew up military so i moved around a
lot so i wound up being both part of the
weird
uh drama choir group of kids and also
the kids that did drugs under the
bleachers
um so it wasn't so much a battle for my
affections as
i found a way to make both groups
somehow hornier and craftier
there you go i'm a uniter i tend to
really relate to like high school movies
where it's like a kid who can't like
bring themselves to speak and then joins
like speech and debate like it's more
that kind of like
indie and then than something like mean
girls
yeah okay uh i'm i i guess i
i thought i was in ender's game but i
was in
you know freak the mighty or something
like that
were you in space is that was that part
of your high school experience
basically yeah you know you think you're
the chosen one and then you zoom back
and oh it's
it's freaks and geeks like you're not or
freak the mighty also a good book
freaks and geeks that yes that was very
relatable to me
i was the president of the drama club so
obviously i was the coolest person
there you go there you go all right
let's keep playing
move over breakfast club so long
clueless
and who said you could sit with us
netflix girls because it's time for one
of the best high school movies of the
early 2000s
in fact one of the best things from the
but that really isn't saying much let's
just get the nostalgia for that decade
okay trust us back before lohan was
making reality shows
pop albums and court appearances and
before rachel mcadams
was getting so as i i did a little
research i was like all right i'm going
to try to find some like crazy
uh shots from lindsay lohan's beach club
show where she
opened up a beach club in mykonos
cancelled after one season
yes for not having enough drama like
they're just it just wasn't juicy enough
there wasn't enough like uh
drink thrown or whatever and it's like
and and the clips bear it out like the
worst i could find was her being like
you guys really got to show up to work
on time
and the funny thing it seems so boring
there were also rumors when it was
coming out that it was not only because
our reality shows are obviously like
it's not
reality like they're scripted or
whatever but if this was entirely
fraudulent like there was never a open
lindsay lohan beach club
it was just for the show and even with
that they couldn't make it juicy enough
to write something
well after her experience i think you're
writing it anyway
just have her straight up murder someone
yeah like why not it's a scripted show
well i think after she did have that
show with oprah where it was supposed to
be like come into my real life
right um on own and the entire show was
about how lindsay
uh kept running from the cameras every
time they're like but our job is to come
into your real life and she'd be like
but also you can do that outside my
front door
um and then eventually oprah had to be
like hey what's going on and she was
like nothing it's fine and so i think
after that she was like yeah just like
i will come in every once in a while and
and and give everybody a pep talk
and then i'll go away and try to steal a
kid like that
that's right yeah but there was like i
saw like even a blog post where like a
person who like spent some time on
mykonos they were like we checked in
like eight
times this place is never open it is
just for the show wow
everything you know is is a lot i know
jeez how can you trust me
i was just gonna book my ticket to
lohan's before lohan festival
all right let's keep going pop albums
and court appearances
and before rachel mcadams was getting
some strange they were in mean girls
the funniest comedy to ever be adapted
from a non-fiction parenting advice book
in this hilarious satire that can either
be viewed as a plea for teen girls to be
more kind to each other
or an instruction manual for future
sociopaths it could really use an update
though
like how do i destroy the thought of
diss my junk fan cam
please advise welcome um
it took a lot of uh uh researching among
our
uh you know median age late thirties
writing crew to be like what
what with the teens yeah i believe i
believe at one point i said back the
note like
i don't think this is uh this is up to
date but
but what the whatever the team
equivalent of this would be
we did our best with jungkook fan cam
which what i understand is
people record it's like bootleg concert
videos right right but they just zoom in
on the boys
[Music]
of various videos of right just the
member of the group that you
like in particular like zoomed in fun to
watch also they sometimes have like
video effects right they're made to look
like it's like an old vhs or like it's a
thing you handmade
there can be those are edits look i
don't want to say i'm in on tick tock
twitter it's a long thing
yes no but no you're you're very right
um uh there there are the ones where
it's just the one dude or person
uh in a concert and the ones where
people put them all together and then
the ones where they photoshop themselves
in like lying next to the person
watching
that as well i'm sorry what the kids are
doing a lot
it's like fanfic but video now but
you're lying down and this boy is
is dancing on you or around you is this
like when uh
zoomers say like i love this guy i want
him to run over me with a with a steam
truck
[Laughter]
[Music]
tick tock gets weird um and so does
twitter
all right uh i i'd get on there if it
wasn't about to go away right
a huge threat to our national security
and not just because sarah cooper is on
there making fun of the president
it's totally not related to that got him
all right let's keep going to one of the
most racially segregated high schools in
illinois
asian nerds cool asians unfriendly black
hotties
where the popular girls are cruel god
karen you are so
stupid the unpopular girls are vengeful
and manipulative
we turned her best friends against her
and we gave you a foot cream instead of
face washing
the teachers are statutory rapists
and the bus drivers really want to get
kids to school on time
shove it right up your hair
tossed into this jungle is a pause um i
think this
this latest rewatch kind of the the
thing that jumped out to me
is how oh god lizzie kaplan's character
what's her name
janice janice yeah janice is not
she's not not a mean girl no both of
them are mean
people like everyone in this kind of
sucks which i think is ultimately sort
of the point
but i think everyone really focuses on
the plastic so it's like no everyone
sucks
the the the cool kids spend the first
like two minutes there on screen
loudly railing on everyone else around
them who can hear them and one of them
almost starts like crying they're not
nice people
yeah i i think that it's like rachel
mcadams is so good
and those are such good villains that
everybody really focused on that but i
think the point of the movie is that
all of these kids in their own way are
cruel to one another
whether it's like in a burn book or just
being mean or
pointing out that they fart plotting to
destroy someone's
life systematically yeah right like kids
yeah so i mean i think i think that is
what it's sort of getting and that's
like kind of the tina fey speech at the
end where she gets everybody to raise
their hand
they admitting they've been mean you
know i think it's i think that's baked
in
but yes it does it does really come out
in a re-watch
where you're like oh yeah they're all so
horrible yeah
all right keep going tossed into this
jungle
is katie she's from africa i just moved
here from africa
which country you know africa shut up
she doesn't know about basic things like
fashion clicks
or african americans jumbo
what because she was homeschooled by the
parents from get out
this is the fertility boss of the
underbelly tribe i would have
voted for obama for a third term so
watch katie
uh yeah lon you pointed out that like
she's not homeschooled she's no schooled
like she does she comes in with just
zero context on just like the world like
the nature of friendship like i think
they have friends in africa
they might even have cliques who knows
yeah i mean it's like right and like
they have the notion of just because
somebody is a race you're familiar with
they don't speak the language you know
like yeah really they have buildings and
malls and stuff
like that that is actually like kind of
offensive that every time there's a
flashback to africa she's literally in a
field like it's like
it's like not all of africa is the veldt
there's also like cities
like you have to figure that her parents
were really
you know some kind of sociology project
like deep in
in the mix it was jane goodall like they
could have been in nairobi
come on they were interacting with other
human beings so
yeah it's like one person in her
in a field and he's like a tribesman
like it's crazy come on
it's everyone's instagram who's like i
want to go help kids in africa
just pictures of them with like two
people who are like
you spend her whole life up until now on
safari
yeah uh i do uh something i point out in
the in the hundred reasons to watch
video which you guys should all watch
uh immediately before or after this is
um
uh i do like how it made the score uh
even though it's like kind of a paul
simon gracelandish version
of of african music it's still like a
it's refreshing to hear a high school
movie with an actual score and not just
like
simple plan or some 41 or something we
should have gotten lady smith black
mambazo
i know right what a sh what a what a
missed opportunity
keep going watch katie enlist the help
of her gay best friend
and her friend who's mortified people
wouldn't even think she's gay it's not
my fault you're like in love with me or
something
what oh no she did not to infiltrate the
popular clique
known as the plastics a group of
abercrombie and [ __ ] led by regina
george
who's so mean you'll barely care when
the hero stoker eating disorder
i'm only eating foods with less than 30
calories from fat i really want to lose
three pounds
it's called the south beach fat flush
and all you drink is cranberry juice for
72 hours
karen smith the second dumbest weather
reporter from a 2004 film
there's a 30 chance that it's already
raining
and 38 degrees in the middle east and
gretchen weiners
who ironically isn't the girl who made
out with a hot dog made out with a hot
dog
oh my god that was one time together
these vlogs um another thing we talked
about in the in the hundred reasons
video is that this movie started as a r
rated script and we can bet that made
out with was not
the first draft of that show yeah almost
definitely not yeah
but funnier i think because it's just
weird yeah no it's way uh
uh look when you go down and bust down
to p from like
r to x stuff to pg-13 it either gets
weirder or grosser
um or like funnier or grosser to me that
one is one of the ones that's funnier
there are ways that they definitely
could have made that way more gross
also i did have to say when i watched
that uh when i was a kid i was like i
went to the wrong parties
there were no hot dog makeouts at my
parties
wait you you think of that as like a
like a party trick
i i was imagining like that was you know
you walk in you go oh god what have i
seen you know oh no i imagined it as a
party trick
i you know
thinking this is going to be hilarious
and then they were all like and now it's
like the thing that she's tagged with
forever that's my
that's my own internal backstory for the
making
there you go maybe they explore this
more in mean girls too but i mean if you
but if you use the
other verse the r-rated version of the
joke which i won't say then i think it's
somebody walked in on a private moment i
think it changes the context
yeah oh icicle
okay keep going heather these von
duchesses will worthlessly scheme to
stay popular in a fiendish plot to
duh that's pretty much it but they wrote
some mean stuff in a private journal
years ago so
monsters follow along on katie's
uncomfortably true-to-life evolution
pause for a second you're lon you're
very pro-regina
i'm i'm pretty pro-plastic i have to say
i have to go through
well because here's what what it
ultimately came down to is
going back and re-watching the movie
like the only character who's like
intentionally funny throughout is regina
like
everybody else like they're funny to us
the viewer watching from home because we
appreciate the irony of the situation
but they're not
actually very funny just i guess um
damien is also funny
but um but regina's constantly like
actually be
i mean it's mean and cutting but she'd
be the one who's fun to hang out with
like i would rather be
karen or gretchen in this scenario than
like
janice or katie is what i'm saying like
i'd want to be friends with regina she's
funny
regina karen gretchen and lon i want to
see that movie
i love that i want to see what you look
like on wednesdays
on wednesdays we wear dr strange shirts
also the burn book thing is really real
um i i think i don't know oh yeah no
that happened
but like that happened when i was like
that happened at my high school as well
there was one day where
it was like exactly like in this where
people like posted
xerox copies of stuff that was in the
book i did not get it yeah my brother
got uh
got uh not expelled he got he couldn't
go to like the fun party at the end of
the year because he wrote mean things in
his
own yearbook next to uh people's photos
but then like
yeah he was just taking notes just maybe
he's just taking notes
when i was in junior high and this is
just like a consequence of army kids
growing up too fast uh uh it wasn't even
burn books it was burn index cards and
then a group of people would come up to
you and be like
here's what we all decided about you and
then you had to just go hide in a
classroom and cry
or hit someone and get suspended wow yes
that's the rules i tend to merits
radford
i got a ring right hook
all right keep going follow along on
katie's uncomfortably true to life
evolution from wholesome silver kid
to out of control party girl as she
steals a guy so nice
he dated regina twice gets a teacher
arrested
no i bet she sells drugs on the side to
pay for a pathetic divorce and incites a
riot
but it's nothing a single apology and an
afternoon of trust falls can't fix
see now everyone is friends with
everyone oh it's still full of clicks
just the members changed well at least
they can kill the ones who get too
powerful
so revisions yeah the takeaway seems
to be not like we shouldn't have clicks
but like you just need to find the right
click for you
just diversify your clicks man like the
first thing it's like
you all of your clicks need to come
together do you make sure that you have
a one of every kind
instead of having all of the clicks
mixed over regina was actually a jock
like all along right the u.s is a salad
bowl and if you just get all the
terrible people and shake them up into a
bowl and
distribute them like equally then you're
fine
i think it was also like you you you you
find your place
in your group and whatever but you don't
have to be cruel to
the other people who aren't part of it i
guess if i was going to try my best
but the thing with the with the little
plastics was like they will rise again
we need to dismantle them by any means
necessary right yeah
that's also another excuse for school
bus violence to kind of
to kind of pull that threat all the
great equalizers
yes they thank god for killer school
buses
to re hit the reset button every few
years when things get out of hand
well triggered right now guys sorry
keep going you're the ones who get too
powerful
of all time cool stop trying to make
fetch happen
it's not going to happen you go glen
coco
that leans on the strengths of great
future stars and just the right amount
of
pause for one second um uh uh funny but
also awful
is that uh tina fey puts real people's
names in her scripts there's a real
glenn coco
who's now that oh no that poor man
yeah like how sick is he at that line of
dying oh boy
cursed i mean i guess like she wouldn't
know that this throwaway line would
become the thing that people quote but
yeah i also didn't know that it wouldn't
seinfeld also like all
like so many seinfeld characters are
just named after like
writers and producers that they know and
like that must be
it must be a nightmare to like be one of
those guys
we've talked about this 500 days of
summer opens with the dude who wrote the
movie literally
talking about the woman he wrote the
movie about and calling her a [ __ ] and
using her oh god
real name yeah like lloyd braun is a
real guy
and like that's also the crazy guy from
seinfeld it's like super iconic now
yeah i mean that's like a a common
enough name but glenn
coco is very specific it is a funny name
like if you knew somebody with that name
you you'd store it in the back you
should have needed a funny name for
something
yeah we've all got a couple of those um
all right
sir
of gilbert people to anchor a film with
a wise and lasting message
math is for losers i think i'm joining
them athletes
no no no no i'm athletes i pretended to
be bad at math so that you'd help me
they didn't join those stupid athletes
i'm a mathlete a nerd
you can't join mathletes it's
universally reviled
story yeah katie great job
regina the teenage graphics quiz lemon
director of education stephen poob wet
hot american mother
fetch should we just explain that like
people need to watch
uh that's snl sketchy my favorite snl
sketch
is it called doctor's office like yeah
it's called something really generic
like
bad doctor's offices will ferrell is a
terrible doctor
molly shannon is his nurse uh and
there's just a cameo appearance by tim
meadows
as dr steve steve and it is amazing and
hilarious and
it just feels like the sketch goes off
the rails like instantly
yeah is it improvised like something
something went off script you could tell
there was
a script there it's like he's delivering
bad news like he's in he's an ob
gyn and he's giving this couple bad news
about their baby but he's crazy
but like it just goes in these weird
directions yeah okay it's dr beeman's
office test results
right yeah it's pretty infamous like
it's an infamous sketch there you go
yeah and it is it is one of the crown
jewels of tim meadows long and storied
career
definitely okay let's keep playing
red hot american mother fetch happens
amanda huggin kiss leslie kaplan
big gay pal river doll
you plus me equals us and youtube
comments
grassy little [ __ ] fat virgin styke
white chicks
don schweitzer has a huge ass who would
write that
cardi b megan the stallion just
spitballing here
there you go what what a different world
the early 2000s
today would not that's not an insult
anymore yeah
um well there you go that's our trailer
for white chicks uh
white chicks another
just gem waiting out there for us
someday maybe we'll double feature it
with joanna man who knows
um uh if you're watching this far thank
you
uh please subscribe if you haven't
already and hit the like button
and the little bell and some other fun
things we have coming up for you
uh this friday there will be a fandom
five trivia contest fandom five five
five trivia trivia trivia
uh on the subject of dragon ball is it
dragon ball z
or all the dragon balls it's it i mean i
i think we're just calling it dragon
ball but it is it's going to be dragon
ball z
and then like there was one show after
that that's like part of the same dragon
ball z
dragon ball figure definitely not dragon
ball gt but it will be dbz heavy more
than anything
dbz heavy with a sprinkling of super so
uh
no gt we were told explicitly so that
will not be that gt is not that bad
that's pretty bad
um but yeah you know have your have your
facts and figures ready uh you
get super saiyan all the way to all the
levels that they've created
at what level of super saiyan are they
on now it's got to be like 20.
overnight literally super saiyan god i
believe there you go super saiyan god
what's after god you be the judge uh all
right and i'll write these questions i
promise
so somebody who knows dragon ball and is
more capable than me
it took care of this one um and
uh we have a aforementioned hundred
reasons to watch mean girls uh
also up on this channel so please give
that a watch watch
reason 75 will blow your mind
you won't believe reason 79 um so
check that out uh i believe we have some
things that we cut from this
so why don't we cue those up and play
them for the people and the teachers are
statutory rapists
but don't worry it's funny because uh
his victims don't speak english
is that the joke hmm i'm not sure that
one hits the same these days
it's funny because it happens karen
smith
who's really more of a gwyneth if you
ask me and gretchen weiners
i'm sorry wieners wow forget katie i
wanna know how a kid named wieners
called her way to the top
see a popular kid named wieners you run
you run for your life
and gretchen wieners wieners
this movie should just be called hot
rich girls vintage lilo could poop on
someone's face and get away with it
she probably did at some point you can't
join mathletes it's social suicide
thanks damian way to know numbers nerd
the limit does exist and it's your face
starring lilo and stitch
the african gas queen the thought chick
the other notebook ploy george
petty and pink nice principles
batman leslie yup perky and recreation
the uptight citizens brigade pop tart
stop trying to make gretch happen zatina
britt tamland the weather chanel punky
booster
american pie rule intentions
the line the book in their wardrobe
burnt book smart
high school rusical
oh there you go intentions was very good
i thought when i went when when gruel
intentions popped up in
into the brain it was just like how how
could this not be the one but all right
as a musical theater nerd i will say the
book for this is actually really good
um oh for the musical yeah the book uh
sorry
nerd talk when you talk about the book
the book specifically means like the
songs
of the so they take this into a musical
the book is actually really good
um unlike the book for beetlejuice which
is oh
okay well uh let's talk about some with
the sand worm coming onto the stage i
want to see
it some viewer mail uh uh speaking of
which
prince of poopoo right uh does anyone on
the honest trailers crew have any
opinions on the mean girls musical
danielle your time to shine that was it
yeah no like that i mean it's
it's really good um they're really uh uh
i think
it's really hard to adapt these for
musicals and
it's one of those things where just like
we are doing with franchises
um when it comes like movies and media
and tv musicals are doing the same thing
where there's really been
like a hotbed of people and there always
has been but it's been really prevalent
lately
of adapting like these popular things
from 10 20 years ago
um but the book for this is actually
really good i like it i like the musical
i think it's great again
i think it's one of the best of the new
musicals of the last five years it's not
my favorite but i think it's really good
and especially adapted because i from
the book for beetlejuice
um for me doesn't there's a there's a
song called dead mom
that's just like hey dead mom and like
that's most of the song so it's just not
my
my deal but i really really like the
mean girls musical um
it is worth looking up the book or at
least like the stuff
um that's available on youtube online
what's like what's the big
show-stopping number from the mean girls
musical
well for me it's apex predator which i
think is the really good one that's the
one where janice is like explaining like
uh um right here's who regina george is
what she's all about
yeah okay yeah it's kind of like a uh
it's like a alto e
uh seconds of wow nerd it is a really
good song
solid
[Laughter]
it's got kind of a sondheim bridge
mate oh there you go uh is mean girls a
movie
about an attempted coup on a monarchy
that ends in a socialist revolution the
crown is broken into pieces and everyone
gets a piece
well you know it could be read that way
i always thought that she should just
give the crown to damien like
just give him the crown just say like
you know what i shouldn't be it uh
this will actually make you happy so
pander
is what you're suggesting she should
have handered more
i don't know what you say i can always
say it is weird because it's like what
you're supposed to wear it it doesn't
really mean anything if you have a
little broken piece of it but
chandra i would really like to read your
hot take uh uh your whole article on
that like please write
uh uh 600 to 700 words on that and send
that to me immediately yeah it's kind of
like in this essay i will
i'm genuine like i want to read it yeah
i'll check that out as well uh
brian singleton writes i'm going to
burger king anyone want anything
i will say that uh not to not to deny us
future sponsorships but burger king's
probably the lowest tier for me
of if i'm leaving for fast food there's
like five places i'm going before then
are we are we putting is yoshinoya on
this list because that is below
that's definitely that's the basement
and then we can build from there but
burger king's not
much higher yoshinoya has good rice
maybe if you just get rice okay yeah
just
big bowl of rice all right well i don't
think we're going to top that one
um uh it's making me hungry that's what
i'm saying
no don't eat any ocean oil i'm gonna
yeah i'm gonna take a
i get the rice from your chinoy then i
take the whopper patty and make a little
uh
little hawaiian special yeah okay there
we go uh that's that's the mean girl's
honest trailer experience you've just uh
you've just experienced mean girls from
front to back
from honest trailer to honest trailer
commentary and we hope you'll come back
next week
where we will be dissecting and
eviscerating and absolutely
blasting out uh uh dane cook style
um a show that actually has a very 2004
sensibility
um though it came out recently uh and i
think it's one you're going to want to
watch with all your mates
so check it out and uh and we'll see you
here
next week here for honest the honest
trailer commentators thanks for watching
[Music]
you